que viva Taiwán libre
recibimiento de honor al presidente de
Guatemala alexandro yamatei en Taiwán
estoy muy complacida de recibir hoy al
presidente yamatei con honores militares
la relación entre taipei y ciudad de
Guatemala desafía la postura de una sola
china principal política del gobierno de
Beijing cualquier acto que ignore las
tendencias mundiales y la justicia
internacional se adhiere obstinadamente
a una posición equivocada condenada al
fracaso sólo 13 países en el mundo
reconocen la soberanía de Taiwán de los
cuales Guatemala y Paraguay Son los
únicos en América Latina Honduras retiró
recientemente su reconocimiento
lazos que el presidente guatemalteco
quiere fortalecer profundizando la
cooperación en varias áreas
especialmente en los campos de la salud
la economía y la infraestructura básica
como ya es costumbre cada vez que un
mandatario funcionario de estado visita
La Isla la República popular china se
pronunció enérgicamente
le aconsejamos al gobierno guatemalteco
que no ayude ni instigue a un malhechor
ni que actúe de forma egoísta en contra
de la tendencia internacional y los
deseos del pueblo guatemalteco
desde que china se consolidó como la
segunda Economía del mundo la comunidad
internacional ha preferido reconocer a
Beijing que a taipei sin embargo Taiwán
sigue recibiendo apoyo en el campo
militar de su Aliado más importante
Estados Unidos Taiwán está acelerando el
abastecimiento de armas ante la amenaza
militar de China
luego de que Beijing mantuviera durante
tres días constantes ejercicios
militares para poner a prueba las
capacidades en condiciones reales de
combate